[Music]
in no justice news submitted by geo is
body goes oh thank you
magnet that not it it is as of right now
as of right now really oh thanks
a judge tried to find a man one dollar
for every time he groped an underaged
girl just one dollar put him in jail you
understand so they're making it okay if
you pay for pretty much so this takes
place here in the United States in
Florida
no Pennsylvania I would have never
guessed
I always forget about Pennsylvania
that's why they can do weird [ __ ] like
this Kenny what are the people in
Pennsylvania not Mormons Puritans that
Pennsylvania robot is almost late mama
squeakers Perkins quicker I don't even
know yeah I just found out
I thought meal there we go the quick
oatmeal so for every girl to pay a
dollar that's what this judge is trying
to find that's uh not that harsh of a
scent that means
Donald Trump can grab billions of
[ __ ] and it's interesting you bring
them up because he is mentioned in this
article as well so there's Common Pleas
senior judge named Lester
hello that's so [ __ ] fitting last
Lester the molester Lester the most
humorous what yeah
so this judge he's under fire because he
suggested a $1 fine force every single
time this particular man inappropriately
grabbed and groped a fifteen year old
without her control my god what the
[ __ ] [ __ ] what where his other ideas
I thought were really bad guy not ah not
the one dollar per group that's the one
at the time of the crime this the
offender he was under the age of 18 but
pretty much you're not charging $300
fine he couldn't pay it for whatever
reason so then that's when the judge
said fine I'm going to give him a 90-day
postponement she has to do community
service and he has to pay a three dollar
fine and he asked how many times did you
touch her and the victim was there in
court and she said
I'm gonna say about six times maybe and
the judge said a six dollar fine oh my
god what's the logic behind it I can't
figure it out exactly so then that's
when I said this curls like bugs no
one's in my corner yes in front of her
he says okay well then six bugs so now
she walked out of there feeling like a
chance [ __ ] trick did does a judge
station busted but she's only worth a
dollar or does he think she's I really
had is like I understand you dog look
yeah you're probably going to grab her
2,000 more times
was it gifted and target it's so [ __ ]
so then a and it's Assistant District
Attorney interrupted the judge with an
instruction saying it is highly
inappropriate to tell a young girl that
inappropriate touching is worth $1 a
time so then that's when the judge
restated the fact that the offender
couldn't pay the 300 other fine and
asked the ad no time yeah he asked the
ABA is he wanted the offender to be
thrown in jail and that's when the ABA
said well that's not the point
and then the judge said of course it's
the point and then he ended up waving
the see complete all in line cookies a
[ __ ] annoyed yes
that's crazy so what's happening to that
judge yeah this journalist [ __ ]
[ __ ] so then one point during the
hearing when they're discussing the
actions of the offender the judge said
listen I can name at least one adults
that think that's okay he's an important
guy which he was referring to trunk so
then that was the important is the
tongue read himself hmm what are you
talking about himself or even that yeah
so then later on after this whole court
ordeal happen she was asked by a news
source if he was implying that she was
referencing to trump and then like you
know by transcribing by the [ __ ] thing
and then his response was I was
referencing that we live in this really
crass inappropriate society where people
talk like this all the time that was his
response to that so was this like some
weird
kind of
jab at society you elected you elected
this man but now you want to get mad at
this kid like just taking a personal
that's stupidest [ __ ] if it is law
license could get revoked I hope it does
he's probably gonna resign after this
she probably was one boob but that girl
I have cows her head after hearing that
[ __ ] you know like she [ __ ] went to
court to testify that's hard as [ __ ]
the merciless yeah and then you and you
go to court to seek justice yeah and
that's what she here's a dollar
and even before that you hear oh well he
can't afford to pay yeah like you feel
bad for him like what the [ __ ]
exactly so a spokesperson for the County
District Attorney's Office that conduct
has no place low his sis judge the
judges conduct has no place in our
judicial system and the district
attorney will bring it to the attention
of the appropriate person and it's
necessary the Judicial Conduct Sport
awesome yeah so then exactly so then at
the end of the hearing the judge told a
court that he felt bad for the victim
but there isn't much he could do what
there's everything he's been looking in
law if you can make up a six dollar fine
you have a lot of [ __ ] time you could
up it maybe a thousand dollars program
yeah no I didn't throw it out of jail he
said he was not trying to mock or to
generate the victims experience the
judge says that the attorneys did not
give him a sentence suggestion so he
tried to find some way of punishing the
offender on his own oh my what this
still doesn't make any sense if you get
to make [ __ ] up make up something that's
really gonna this kid has no incentive
to stop groping underage he has more
incentive to [ __ ] broke go now yeah
that's it a dollar under this judge had
a daughter like if you would find this
fair but yeah grab my dollars don't even
do dollar what a piece of [ __ ] it looks
like a clean man doing white face yes
yeah yeah it looks even a haircut looks
freaky yeah also looks bigger way the
wind is blowing in there yeah yeah that
is [ __ ] tragic I don't know what I
would do as a parent if I heard that I
will probably just find the dude after
the court hearing and the beat his
[ __ ] ass with the black mass one the
kid or this one
both the 18 year old no I would be
[ __ ] judges ass okay that's a wrap
for you you ain't getting nothing done
ha ha ha ha bet you can come up with a
sentence then I will take him into a
shed cover my face and beat his ass
constantly tell him to go change it I'll
find them again and I guarantee to come
up with a bruised face and maybe we
should do like a dozen Oh funny
over the course of multiple years when
they were in middle school in high
school that's when he kept searching
this victim and that's what this entire
since middle school middle school in
high school yeah yeah he was on human
race to more than half I felt like the
judges a rapist I'll only make sense I
feel like no because like from what I've
seen those are the ones who pretend to
be the advocates the mole ooh they got
that [ __ ] that wolf enough sheep's
clothing like how all those dudes who
like their job is to break down
prostitution rings yeah and then you
find their names in the prosecution
books actually have is out there what
don't they go undercover or something I
remember like saying like they wouldn't
use their actual names every yeah
reading some headline thing something
along the lines of like this state will
no longer allow detectives to have sex
with them to do things for their
investigation
that's why that would be an interesting
job to have yeah just so sad you know
it's really effective this girl got
absolutely notice
told us here we go they just say that
she's 15 so I don't know if that's now
or at the time that all this was
happening
hmm we'll probably now because it's from
junior high all the way to high school
this poor girl had to like relive those
memories
talk about it out loud in public and
then to not get anything out of it
some community says he got community
service that days emotive we're also
planning to turn to criminal now who she
doesn't trust the law system she nice oh
yeah they launched our own hands you
can't have the saliva evil yeah and a
lot of people get into games that they
don't trust the cops don't trust a
traditional system of meeting yeah I
mean yeah like what other form of
Justice can she get if she doesn't put
in her own man
she's about to kill him now think that
one three that we talked about a while
ago where there was that one girl she
ended I forgot if she killed them or she
shot him or something that's the person
that had abused her and then the judge
ended up being really lenient on her
because the judge is like well the court
actually failed her previously I forgot
the entire story I think he reported it
but yeah I'm like that was a similar
comment that's rare for them to go be
lenient yeah like they'll [ __ ] not
prosecute you're a dagger you get it
justice for yourself and then prosecute
you to the fullest is fun crazy yeah do
you think the case is going to be moved
to another judge for maybe like a
different type of hearing because me
because this judge is under fire right
so like maybe whatever he said it
doesn't count know what you just brought
up a good point though what kind of
hearing was this a civil case I'm not
sure well no because he got community
service that it means it was a criminal
case yeah so the only thing they could
do now is a civil case because I'm
taking a double jeopardy something like
that mean he's already been sentenced
criminally so street justice well but if
he can't pay $300 and you're not going
to give [ __ ] from a single case how's it
going guys don't forget to like the
video because if you don't I will break
your [ __ ] legs thank you so much for
the last video don't forget to click
right here or I'll break your [ __ ]
arms click right here guys
[Music]